Fans of "The Big Bang Theory" can point out plenty
of fun moments from the show's 12 seasons. From
that time Penny, played by Kaley Cuoco, gives
Jim Parsons’ Sheldon the ultimate Christmas gift
to the scene in which Penny solves string theory,
it's hard to get any consensus on which of the CBS
sitcom's seasons viewers like the best, although
most seem to prefer the first six seasons.
Naturally, the actors all have their own
favorite moments, and several of them
come in the Season 4 episode called "The
Agreement Dissection." Parsons told TBS,
"I loved the structure of this episode,
the way I got to sort of take part in two
different story lines: girls
night and the fight over the
roommate agreement at home. It was also
a really fun episode with Mayim Bialik."
And in a 2011 San Diego Comic-Con panel in
which the actors were asked about their favorite
moments from Season 4, Bialik joked that a kiss
between her character, Amy, and Penny was hers.
"I kissed a girl and I liked it."
"What happened to you?"
And then Bialik said more seriously that
the drunken kiss between Amy and Sheldon
was really her favorite. Cuoco also
revealed her favorite moment as being
from that episode since she had to convince
an actor to sexually harass her on-screen.
Cuoco explained that the scene was
her favorite moment of Season 4,
although it was hard for her
to pick just one. She said,
"I guess it was where I had a lovely man have to
grab my ass in an episode when we were
dancing. And he was a little older man,
and he was so nervous. And it was so against
everything he believed in, and I was like,
'Honey, just grab it. Just do it.' And
he closed his eyes and just went for it."
In the episode, Sheldon crashes
a girls' night after lawyer Priya
basically nullifies the roommate agreement
he has with Leonard. When Amy, Penny,
and Bernadette discover that Sheldon can do
the cha-cha, rumba, and waltz, they decide to
take him to a place they can waltz. At a dance
hall, an older man asks Bernadette to dance;
when she says no, he asks Penny, and she
agrees. As he takes her out to the floor,
however, the man takes a certain liberty
until Penny slides his hand back into place.
The man in question is Gabriel Tsai, an actor
who has just a few credits to his name. In fact,
his part in "The Agreement Dissection"
is so small that it isn't one of them.
Wherever he is now, though, he
can say his tiny little role had
an outsize effect on a favorite
episode of "The Big Bang Theory."
Kaley Cuoco was happy to let an older man squeeze
her butt for the aforementioned scene. That said,
while she was clearly committed to the part,
she made sure that Penny was presented as
more than an object for people's desires on
the later seasons of "The Big Bang Theory."
In an interview with W Magazine, Cuoco
said that she was happy for her character
to be sexualized during the earlier
seasons of the sitcom. At the time,
it made sense as Leonard and his
friends were crushing on her. She said,
"I was the cute girl next door to the nerds,
right? It was all about booty
shorts and Juicy Couture zip-ups."
However, both Penny and Cuoco grew up as time
went on, and Cuoco wanted the character to be
shown in a different light to reflect that
— especially when it came to her outfits.
"All of a sudden it's like, 'Can I
have a long sleeve shirt? How about
a slack? How about a loafer? I never
wanna see that high heel ever again!'"